[Música]
bienvenidos a enlace norte américa desde
ciudad de mexico
hoy hablaremos de la ruta de la memoria
por las víctimas en que se ha convertido
el paseo de la reforma la avenida más
emblemática de la ciudad familiares de
desaparecidos se han apropiado de la que
fuera la glorieta de la palma y buscan
dedicar ese espacio a la memoria de sus
seres queridos contrario a la voluntad y
decisión del gobierno local por otra
parte participaremos en uno de los
paseos históricos por la ciudad
recorridos guiados por expertos que
permiten conocer la importancia y el
origen de rincones icónicos de la ciudad
como el multifamiliar miguel alemán el
primer centro urbano moderno de
latinoamérica
porque vivo
ah
[Música]
al morir la palma que daba nombre a esta
glorieta en el epicentro del distrito
financiero familiares de personas
desaparecidas decidieron tomar este
espacio para recordarle al estado la
crisis que se vive en el país con más de
100 mil víctimas desaparecidas tras
colocar fotografías de sus hijos sus
madres o sus hermanos ausentes el
gobierno la retiró provocando así una
confrontación nosotros ya tomamos la
decisión que es nuestra glorieta que es
la glorieta de las y los desaparecidos y
así nos pongan vayas así traten de
impedir que sigamos poniendo las
fotografías de nuestros familiares
nosotros vamos a regresar las veces que
sea necesario en el gobierno de la
ciudad argumentan que se realizó una
consulta virtual en la cual los
participantes votaron por sembrar un
árbol de ahuehuete en lugar de la palma
y reconocen que se trata de una decisión
tomada sólo cambiar un árbol por otro
esta consulta solamente era para definir
qué por qué otro árbol se
sustituye a la palma e incluso la propia
palma estaba ahí pero no no era el
objetivo
si atendía a un homenaje se tendría a un
objetivo en particular o si la propia
palma o el ahuehuete iba a llevar algún
mensaje
social o político no esta glorieta de
los desaparecidos se suma a los varios
anti monumentos que se erigen sobre el
paseo de la reforma el más reciente ahí
donde era la rotonda a colom es el de la
glorieta de las mujeres que luchan que
grupos feministas hicieron suya a pesar
de las autoridades pero lo mismo está el
anti monumento a los 43 en memoria de
los estudiantes de ayotzinapa y el de
los niños fallecidos en el incendio de
la guardería en sonora y el de los
mineros muertos por un derrumbe en
coahuila entre otros varios que se
dispersan incluso más allá de la avenida
justo enfrente de la embajada de eeuu se
ubica el anti monumento a los 72
migrantes más sagrados en san fernando
tamaulipas en 2010 pero es también un
memorial a los miles de migrantes que
han sido víctimas de violaciones a sus
derechos humanos en este país
y también ese más qué significan los los
miles más de personas de mujeres y
hombres niños que han asesinado y que
han desaparecido en este país entre
ellos está óscar antonio lópez enamorado
mi hijo que en el año 2010 lo
desaparecieron en el estado de jalisco
la ruta de la memoria se remonta hasta
episodios trágicos que ocurrieron
décadas atrás es el caso del anti
monumento por las víctimas de la masacre
estudiantil de 1968 en pleno zócalo a
unos pasos se ubica el memorial a las
víctimas de la represión de 1972 el
objetivo de estos lugares es que nunca
nadie pretenda negar ni olvidar los
lamentables sucesos que han marcado la
historia de mexico en muchos de los
cuales no se ha hecho justicia
y así como en la avenida principal está
trazada la ruta de la memoria por las
víctimas otros sitios esconden una
interesante y asombrosa historia es por
ello que la secretaria de cultura puso
en marcha los paseos históricos por la
ciudad en la que distintos expertos
guían a los paseantes por un recorrido
diferente cada domingo con la intención
de que los capitalinos conozcan más
sobre los puntos de interés de la ciudad
y de alguna manera se conviertan en
turistas en su propia casa hoy toca
recorrido por el multifamiliar miguel
alemany
este conjunto de viviendas fue
construido entre 1947 y 1949 por el
reconocido arquitecto mario pani
inspirado en la villa radiante de le
corbusier y su unidad marsella este
complejo alberga edificios de gran
altura para priorizar espacios
destinados a jardines y servicios pane
quiso crear una ciudad dentro de la
ciudad el encargo era de sólo 200
viviendas y él concibió mil 80
departamentos dúplex un hito en la época
sí
adentro cerca de mixcoac es
relativamente esa misma que sería como
el centro más grande a unos pasos se
encuentra la parroquia de la divina
providencia construida en 1968 su diseño
semicircular favorece la cercanía y la
interacción entre el sacerdote y los
feligreses respondiendo al concilio
vaticano segundo un gran domo deja pasar
la luz solar sobre la cruz y hace
brillar los mosaicos cobrizos de estilo
bizantino sin duda un templo de
vanguardia gracias por acompañarnos en
enlace norteamérica desde ciudad de
méxico soy mario carbonell y mi
compañera en cámara lizette romero hasta
pronto
[Música]